as an activist with students for justice
in Palestine at NYU I've been called
many things including a self-hating Jew
anti-semitic I was called a member of
al-qaeda I was called a terrorist I was
called many racial slurs
because I tweeted in support of
Palestinian human rights I was fired
from my gendered academic position
Rison the suppression we're seeing is in
response to a provides and activism on
campuses especially Israel itself and
Israel advocacy organizations in the
United States
see this and the BDS movement as a big
threat to their legitimacy universities
are meant to be places of unfettered
conversation and the First Amendment
considers litical speech to have the
highest level of protection if this
protection doesn't apply to the most
controversial or offensive or so-called
uncivil speech then it's free speech is
meaningless
you